the taliban are finally going to lose
the support of liberals
do you know why not because of what
they're doing to
women or not even not because of what
they're doing to americans or anything
like that
they they committed an unforgivable sin
the taliban
painted over a mural of george floyd
they did oh you oh you're
we're probably gonna end up nuking the
taliban before the day is through you
can't you can do a lot but you can't
paint over a mural of george st george
no
there
there's actually a very good reason why
they're painting over the mural i mean
it's funny that it's ridiculous that
there are murals to george floyd but
the reason they're painting over the
mural is because george floyd is a is a
symbol of western imperialism
crazy as that is to say
george floyd
and the rainbow flag which they flew
over the embassy in kabul those are the
new symbols of western empire
and we think that's weird here in the
west because in many ways those are
symbols that are meant to undermine the
christian west
the the
george floyd mural the blm ideology is
is a an ideology that states that the
west is evil
right the pride flag is a
is a symbol that says that
christianity is wrong it's a symbol that
says that our traditional views of sex
are wrong
and yet
those are both still symbols
of the west they're not associated with
any other civilization and they're
making universal claims about every
place on earth including afghanistan
which is why they don't like it
no doubt cnn is going to accuse the
taliban
of white supremacy they they these
these pashtun militants they're such
white supremacist and white supremacists
i'm so glad you enjoyed that show that
makes me feel good please leave me a
comment if you want to say hey michael i
like that show that was fun you can
catch the whole episode here at youtube
or what i would recommend
take out your phone go to the podcast
app apple podcast spotify google play
stitch or wherever you go
type in the michael knoll show
you type that in i guess you're probably
using your thumbs you type that in it
might not even come up at the top
sometimes they like to
push this down a little bit even though
it's it's the michael knowles it's big
show you know subscribe leave a five
star review
i really appreciate it we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]